welcome to this video I'm playing
chromis from from Norway I have a
100-percent score against him that's
Lexi of this if this continues a French
defense and am playing a nice yet Paul
position check oh this is a very
dangerous line until them the the main
problem is that I I don't really know I
don't really know it this feels very
normal but how to continue now may be
with a 505 a form or something like that
maybe maybe
yeah I need to get the porn back there
is what a bond temporarily I hope okay
for when all night a six was my idea
maybe maybe this is okay threatening 95
now yeah interesting now I cannot castle
long that's the normal idea fo hang so
he cannot cancel all yeah and he still
has the porn there's some way to get it
back Knight g4 94 maybe 90 form but this
weakens my um my deep on 94 rookie one
for a rock d 1 for example hmm it's not
nice not really that's some way some way
to get it back maybe Bishop g4 okay come
on let's let's start with this setting
up the pin oh that's interesting he just
allows me to take one of three hmm there
well I would have done I would have
allowed that it can take be seven okay I
thought this was as IDM it wasn't okay
what now I mean this looks really a bit
dangerous the rook here can can swing
over to g6 sir maybe maybe night d 7 so
that i can go to e5 maybe
look g6 and 95 I don't think the forward
move like night age five helps and 94 it
was too early
yeah and you can eat the tempo I need
the terminal now here I probably has
just roped you one yeah maybe this
materialistic approach really works
grabbing all the pawns I mean it works
against my play I don't think it's
really good but it's it's working
against what I'm doing yeah all right
you can play rook to e1 here I guess
okay i have 96 maybe this is a way to
find 96 d 5 is hanging that's the
problem if i take here i cannot i cannot
get gag look at the queen is not playing
but coming it's not playing
96a also has see form probably yeah no
choice define things I cannot allow him
to take it not just like that that's a
good move good defensive wounds look
aged six is not on
okay it's not nice I have really it
feels like I should have I should have
had some chances at least but i didn't i
didn't find it I didn't find anything
here
very unsatisfactory gamer enemy
this is some tricks here some trick
identify trade queens i might as well
resign now 56 is a complete joke and I
can just trade Queens and win when
easily
ok 6 just Kingi to it's not even a
threat
very little hope very very light money
yeah trying with one move tricks ruki
one checkmate yeah it's very very easy
to see check black reason I have such
bad shape that I even lose against the
sky I've got the 11 hundred percent
before but that is such a bad play I'm
not saying that but at least you are you
good customers you should take some
points away but I really I really played
this badly I cannot believe this at all
I made for what that he can weekend
Asking side and I can swing the recover
at least that it feels like not the
optimal play but maybe it's not so
terrible computer likes wide it just
feels strangely materialistic to wrap a
pawn here and get away with it ok better
seems to be Quincy 8 intending Queen
edge free yeah but I don't I don't
really have from a good piece
coordination at the moment it feels like
there's something I mean but it's
probably not not not serious yeah and
you can just take it i mean just check
the main problem is the counter play
against the deep on right here here I
can hear the good news Bishop c5 and
black is fine the computer is always
always quick to spot stuff like that and
the good thing is I don't even know what
the point is not at all i don't
understand the move at all that's great
ok let's see if it takes with the bishop
tweenage form hmm with an advantage for
black really why okay well that's this
threat and this threat either dicey dad
Queen B 5 just Roxy 8v how r this is I'm
impossible for a human to play yeah i
understand i mean they are threats but
ok Knight takes what about this again
this move isn't the strange I mean it's
really the bishop was just giving giving
him no less this lost giving itself up
to to get this counter play going 95
queen for my b 5 rook c8 probably and
now going here yeah but this is not a
win or anything for black it's playable
maybe something like that and very weird
very weird stuff ok i played this move
which yeah I it feels wrong I know but
the fire food was hanging it Bishop c5
didn't didn't cross my mind
yet he I probably just lost I mean this
is very very convincing I can only fish
for some projects and I did not it
didn't materialize yeah this is some a
dangerous line if you like me don't turn
no the opening a change a tale something
okay mom hey black and actually played
that one at least tactical am not sure
if it is a good news then get this back
out this should be okay for like I guess
yeah i don't i didn't i didn't know that
the opening really complicated stuff
that he played played a really good game
defending her defending and attacking d5
at same time nice job okay thanks for
watching